so um this is something i noticed when i
heard you i listened to your
conversation with judeon and i enjoyed
it because i think you guys are very
good in contrast um but do you agree
with this do you believe that perception
is reality
yeah
okay
when i watch you speak you know what i
think i think that you believe that your
perception is reality in that
you're convinced that the way that you
view the world sometimes is so accurate
that irrespective of what other people
are saying you're like i already know
which is why i think at one point you're
during your conversation with judeon
judeon said to you yo before the
person's even speaking done speaking
you're like but you said you're not
listening sneako i'm listening i'm
listening no you're not you're not
you're listening
you already have what you want to say in
your mind and you literally you
literally said this in your videos
you've literally heard you say this clip
you say you don't listen to what people
say you go on and assume what they're
gonna say bro you know how many clips on
tick tock i've seen where you assume
what the girl was going to say but then
she said something different you're like
oh [ __ ] i was not expecting that and
when he called john you said yeah
because i already know what they're
going to say and 95 percent of the time
i'm right and then judea comes back to
you and he says no you don't actually
know what they're going to say you were
wrong a few times
i
mean hearing you a lot of your
conversations i noticed it's the same
thing when you had your conversation
with don it's like i think
you're not listening nearly as well as
you believe you are and as a result when
you're having these conversations with
these people it feels very disconjointed
it feels disconnected um
and i think there's one thing that you
said that i thought was really peculiar
i think judeon says you got two ears one
mouth speak less listen more and your
response was but were streamers
which made me laugh
uh you have two ears
and
you have two ears and one mouth
listen more speak less
okay we're streamers we talk for a
living yeah we talk for a living and
stuff like that like that's obvious but
you can let the person
finish
bro but you know like
i mean i'm not like
i think streaming is dope i think you
get up online you talk for hours you go
through a bunch of stuff but because you
speak at such lengths and you don't have
nearly as much time to in
to taking information sometimes you just
i just talk you're not making much sense
okay
i had this series you've seen the one
minute podcast before right abba
yup i have interviewed people on the
street you've done street interviews for
a long time too
the general realization that i've come
to from interviewing people and i do
listen i listen to so many people like
every one minute podcast to do it once a
week is like three hours long and i talk
to so many normies getting off the train
every single day i don't interrupt them
i let them talk
my
after years of doing it use the street
interviews before that what i've come to
realize is most people don't think most
people just believe what they're told
most people accept the reality that's in
front of them and the reason why i think
that i i can predict people quickly is
the general
idea that people don't people trust the
elites too much people trust what
they're told too much and they they put
faith into people who have power
and you shouldn't because they don't
care about you so everyone is virtue
signaling everybody has this false
empathy everyone has a false idea and my
conversation with judeon was annoying
because he's defending people that are
silencing him he got banned on twitch
and he's still defending
the platform that banned him
like why are they censoring him like
people don't never think about that like
i talked with destiny on the debater he
got banned on twitch too and he's like
well i said some bad things i'm like you
should be fighting against that freedom
of speech is dead you know what they
promote on twitch hot tub streamers sip
behavior they want to have men just go
and feeding all their money to this
platform and taking away their power i
think you're conflating two things i
think you could look at twitch and say
they did some they do some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] and also recognize the ways in
which your behavior contributes to a
negative situation this is just like any
relationship that you have you could say
that your partner cheated on you and
that they were [ __ ] up in that
relationship you could also look at your
own behavior within that relationship
and say you know what i was neglectful i
didn't listen to my partner i didn't
treat them really well two things can be
true at the same time judeon could have
been wrong by twitch and judeon may felt
that he owed pokemane uh okay
both of those things can be true
why do you think he felt like he owed
pokeman an apology
that's for judeon to know but that's my
business what do you think to be honest
with you i didn't even look up the
situation that deeply so i don't know
the engine i don't know what exactly he
said i know he said some stuff off the
cuff and that she feels i don't know
that so i'm not gonna speak on that but
as a man if i say something about
somebody else and i don't like what i
said and i said it publicly i'll
apologize publicly not because somebody
else told me not because youtube's
breathing down my neck because i feel
like i did something wrong part of being
a man is being accountable to yourself
and that means that you showcase that
accountability outwardly so if i say
something about you right even if you
don't call me out even if you don't
demand an apology i'ma still come out
and say you know what yo last week i
[ __ ] up right i was talking about
sneako and i said something that i think
is foul even if you like yo it's not
necessary i still apologize because it's
in me you get what i'm trying to say i
think it's very great for so many people
to look at themselves and be like
i was wrong and we need more of that
because too many people get up on these
platforms yeah and and always talk about
others oh women trash women are trash
[ __ ] you live in your mom's basement
and you ain't showered in a week yeah
what's wrong with you yeah yeah nobody
wants you everybody's talking about
others oh the other gender is the
problem oh they're the reason why i
don't get any no no it's you most of the
time ninety-five percent of the time
that's why i will not i will not get on
anybody who gets up on here and says you
know what this is why i [ __ ] up and i
and i wanna i wanna hold that on me you
get what i'm saying it's too much it's
too much everyone else it's not enough
looking inward
so that that's what i would say about
that i agree
chad is saying that you're you're kind
of you you ride the fence a little bit i
could i think playback does the same
thing i think um
the a lot of commentary channels they
want to go red pill and they decide to
take like if they make one red pill
video they'll balance it out by doing
um like a woke video in turn so that you
have more mass appeal do you think
that's what you do
uh no but why why do you think that's
what we do why do you think that we're
doing that
to get a wider audience and so that you
don't get cancelled
right i understand the intention that
you're putting behind understand like
the mentality why do you think that
we're doing it
what what have you seen from us that
convinces you that we're being
disingenuous
i don't know about disingenuous um but
yeah look
well that is what you're insinuating
which is yeah
why do you think that
maybe it's not intentionally
disingenuous but maybe you are trying to
appeal to everybody and you're trying to
like
it might be like red pill is just the
truth like i feel like
i i there's no doubt in my mind that
what's about what's really going on
about the gender war that's going on
about the spiritual warfare about what's
really happening in the world and then
you'll make some videos that kind of
like
tote the line
you see what i'm saying and playback
like i talk to agent and like whenever i
say that like they'll make a redfield
video and then immediately make a world
video and then he laughed when i said
that which i if if they laugh then
that's how i know it's true
okay that's a wild uh reach but i get
what you're saying i i would say to you
maybe i don't understand this why is it
that because i agree with some of what
you say because i don't agree with
everything that you say i'm inherently
disingenuous or i'm i'm coming at this
from like i'm trying to appeal to a
group well at the same time i'm behind i
need to catch up on your videos but
what's your what's your take on the
message okay hypothetically even if it's
not me all right let's say you're not
talking about me let's say you're
talking about playback is it not
possible that playback agrees with
certain things within the red pill
community but not everything
maybe i think a lot of people are
brainwashed and people don't want to
fully agree with someone because it's
provocative and because you come off
aggressive so this is a general take i
hear from a lot of people who watch my
videos or watch fresh and fit or the
manosphere stuff uh andrew tate any of
that they'll say like oh i agree with
some things but not everything but in my
opinion it's just
genuine i think you did how often do you
hear i grow some stuff but not
everything
yeah what's wrong with that because it's
like it's just people's way i think of
inserting their opinion
and it's just okay okay okay so here's
the hypothetical right
i am not a religious person whatsoever
however i do think that some aspects of
religion i think are really good okay be
it the idea of that they formulate good
communities that they commune everybody
together for sunday church just people
spend time together that they give
people a set of certain values be it
like love your neighbor this and that
but when they talk about [ __ ] like stone
and gay people i'm like maybe you lose
me okay when they talk about certain
[ __ ] like uh you know you can't [ __ ]
before marriage uh maybe you lose me is
it not possible that i see grief there's
certain aspects
well i think most of life is a middle
ground
okay do you think that there's a gender
war going on
well no no no hold up we we switching
topics right now can we not just stick
to this before we go to something else i
agree with you i agree with what you're
saying
okay okay so then let's go back because
you initially started this with you felt
like
me playing back a couple other groups of
people
were being maybe a bit disingenuous
because we were trying to appeal to the
mainstream i guess the point i'm trying
to relate to you is that
me having been part of the pickup artist
community when i was uh coming in as a
young man and me learning from a lot of
that stuff there was a lot from that
that i could take that was helpful to me
and so i always repeat this stuff and if
you go through my videos you'll see i
repeat a lot of the same [ __ ] i never
said the pick community's perfect i said
some of the [ __ ] that they taught me is
fantastic and i even repeat a lot of
that stuff but it's not because i repeat
some of that stuff that i think
everything is wonderful and most of the
folks who i looked up to in the pickup
artist community when i was there at
like age 19 20
they grew out of it and they tell you in
later years oh i changed my mind about
certain things because life
experience it makes me realize that
certain things that i believed when i
was younger no longer apply
i'm just saying the same could apply for
a lot of other folks in regards to most
things be it the way you view voting the
way you view women like the way i view
women at 18 is not the way that we i
view women at 32. have stuff you believe
in but don't make the stuff that you
believe in consume you in that sense and
there's a lot of stuff they talk about
reflection and pondering that you
realize like okay there's there's
there's a certain sense of like
as you get older and this is true for
most people and you're gonna go through
it yourself you're gonna have a better
view of yourself almost like you're
seeing yourself in the third person you
know you play video games first person
shooting all the time playing a third
person shooter is completely different
because now you got your whole body in
frame you see what it looks like when
you crouch i think as human beings we
gain more of that perspective as we get
older in life if we're reflective enough
and what i used to believe at 21 i no
longer believe now at 32 just because
life's experiences and my own
reflections realize like that's not true
at all maybe it's because you become
more sedentary as you've gotten older
like maybe it's because it's like you're
you've become
less of that aggressive man that you
were at 21 like right now i'm very like
i'm all about my testosterone balls
manosphere [ __ ] and then maybe you're
just 32 and you're like man let me
settle down
you like [ __ ] sneaker
we all do yeah
you
you like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
yeah
believe it or not that [ __ ] gets old
no
100 no
100 and i could point you to you
hundreds of players who are online right
now who have videos of them telling you
new [ __ ] gets old
in fact how about i tell you this one
and this is this is something even
andrew tata says this is something even
andrew tate says
all right
sex becomes overrated after time you
know it's overrated now
yeah he's like he says new [ __ ] like
why do you think that is
because you get used to it it becomes
like when you eat the same food over and
over again it becomes boring
that's why you get new that's why you
get new [ __ ] like you spice it up or
you keep upgrading that's what after
you've had enough new [ __ ] there is no
more new [ __ ] there's always
differences
no you think that after you've had a few
dives you realize dimes ain't nothing
after you've had some baddies you
realize baddies ain't nothing
so what do you why do you think
why do you think so many of these dudes
as they get older life they stop talking
about this [ __ ] nearly as much
because they get older and they're less
testosterone
it's not even that it's you realize like
ruff the the the payout ain't worth the
work in because you get tired you get
older you don't have as much energy
it's like even if you have the energy
you're not because it's not worth the
time you know there's a video there's a
video i like maybe you don't give a [ __ ]
about his opinion but no
i thought it was great it's uh it's one
with shaquille o'neal and he talks about
his divorce with his first wife and he's
like talking about like how you know he
was [ __ ] left right center and she
was giving him kids and um
at one point during this period
he got caught cheating
and um
ended up [ __ ] up the marriage to get
divorced and now you know shaq is i
think closer to 50.
and he says something that i thought was
so telling he says uh looking back now i
realized like i was the one who [ __ ]
most of that up and
you could pull up the clip later if you
ever get a chance i'll send it to you
on discord but he says
the most joyous moments of my life were
coming home and then seeing all my kids
around and then getting spend time with
them and that divorce going through that
whole process that really
stole for me like what i realized was my
biggest joy
i spend time with my nieces now i spend
time with my mom taking her out to
dinner you know showing her good stuff
and i realized like that's that's the
stuff that matters for me
i've had [ __ ] i've had enough of it for
a lifetime that i'm like bro if i get
new when it's not even but when i spend
time with my niece and i'm watching her
like walk for the first time or i'm
seeing her say words like that [ __ ] hits
differently so you giving up on your
balls
it's not even that it's like
you know i've had i've had experiences
where
the [ __ ] was just like in front of me
on the platter and i'm like breath
i just want to sleep early today yeah
you're getting older like that's just
like i'm too tired to [ __ ]
well
it's it's
but if i was faced with the same choice
if i was to see family or things like
that i wouldn't make that same decision
what i'm trying to tell you is your
priority shift as you get older
as you start to get real priority
shifting or is your testosterone just
dropping
no no as a man your testosterone doesn't
drop until like you're 40.
it takes older than you and he's still
on like get [ __ ] [ __ ] i mean he's
talking about how he gets he's not
yeah he talks about he gets boring and
how he's barely on it nearly as much
anymore but every video you watch is
like i wake up and i push two [ __ ]
out of the way are you waking up and
pushing too much
bro you know that he's the last thing a
lot of that [ __ ] for for shits and
giggles okay yeah if you haven't
no no no no no no listen if you're
making money and you're making moves you
ain't got time to be with holes all day
and i'll tell you
and you're really making money you ain't
got time to be with hoes most of the day
and you don't want to because you
realize that making money and being able
to take care of your [ __ ] is far more
rewarding
again you a young man what are you 24 23
23
i ain't mad at you
i ain't mad at you be about that get as
much [ __ ] go do whatever you got to do
i'm just telling you that when you see
people speak differently it's not
because oh they're turning into beta
males or oh they want to be feminist all
of a sudden this life gives you
experience and as a result it shapes a
lot of the way that you think about
stuff ask any [ __ ] who got kids
and talk to them about it and they say
that's the best thing in my life
that's that's the most important and
then your wife leaves you and takes half
your money takes your house takes your
dog that's a separate issue that's a
separate issue that's not i'm talking
about marriages end that way over half
of marriage marriages ended that like
yeah you have the kids in everything
i'm talking about i'm talking about
divorced dads who have kids and tell you
i would never give up a day with my kid
to go be with a hoe he says they'll tell
you i always prioritize my children it's
not because they became beta sips it's
because they understand what's more
important in life what i'm trying to get
to you as a point is life experiences
things that come to be children be it
family be it whatever the [ __ ] it is it
changes the way that you view priorities
in life
and so every time you hear people speak
from a different perspective it's not
their betas or whatever it's just that
life has just changed them through
experience that sounds boring i don't
want to be when i'm 32 i want to be
[ __ ] double the [ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
now i want to be having a bigger house
having like i want to be down the hugh
hefner [ __ ]
that's what makes you excited that's
what keeps your balls going that
community you can't let go of that you
can't let go of your manhood at a
certain age if you give up on that like
oh i like playing macaroni drawings with
my kids you know you know you know what
you sound like you sound like a lot of
young women i know who say they just
want to travel for the rest of their
life and live on the beach and then they
get to 30 35 and you know what they
realize damn i want a husband i want to
i want to have no i want to wait i want
to have kids soon what else
is in the kitchen
okay okay and you know what once they
have those they realize oh this is the
[ __ ] i don't need to be out here in
cancun taking [ __ ] selfies all day
listen it sounds great to be [ __ ]
many many women i'm just telling you
women i'm just telling you always every
guy
that's that's not a good comparison
because a woman saying she wants to
travel and drink martinis and mykonos
all day that's giving up and that's not
doing anything for me to have 10 [ __ ]
in the crib like in bikinis serving me
food i need to constantly be getting it
because if i'm not getting it then they
can't be here they don't respect me so
having constantly having women in my
life is to motivate me more to be the
best man i could be the more [ __ ] i
got the better [ __ ] that are here the
more i'm gonna keep on going women
motivate you
okay listen i'm not mad at you and like
i said i think this just comes down to a
different age so i'm not even going to
try to like convince anything all i'm
going to say is this
you're going to have experiences with
your friends you're going to go to maybe
a specific day you'll take a trip maybe
i'll watch a movie and laugh and that's
going to be a really valuable memory for
you and as you're going to get older
you're going to forget about 95 percent
of the women you [ __ ] but you're
always going to remember the stuff that
you spend with your family the really
beautiful moments and so you don't have
to believe me today you don't have to
leave me tomorrow but
i'm just saying i'm just saying if you
come at a point later on in life where
you start to question certain things
maybe you just think back on this and
just think about it that's all i'm not
i'm not i don't think you got to agree
because you're not at that point in your
life
i do agree like that sounds appealing to
me too like going and watching like a
rom-com that's like cuddling up and she
puts your legs on top and you have a
candle lit that sounds great but
nowadays the way western women think
they always are aiming for more so that
does sound ideal but all of them because
of instagram and because of stuff
they're looking at women don't want to
settle as much as like at the same level
that men don't want to settle what is
your general opinion on the manosphere
my opinion on the manusphere at least
from like a lot of the content creators
that i've seen
um i think there's a need for it which
is what i've always said there's a need
for content that kind of helps you guide
young men because we don't have any
tools i just think that a lot of the
people who are doing the leading aren't
very good at their job but i also say
i'm not going to be one of them people
who's going to take over the spot so i
can't even knock them that hard for
trying to do what they do but sometimes
i like to have a left with some of the
goofy [ __ ] out here i'm like i i ain't
buying that yeah like your girlfriend
needs to delete her instagram
the girlfriend so i've had this
conversation two times my issue isn't
that the girlfriend needs to delete
their instagram my reason is just some
of the reasons that they say is goofy
like if you want to say your girl
doesn't want it you don't want to have
instagram because you don't want her
thirst trapping or having her ass out
online i'm like that's perfectly
sensible to say you don't want your
girlfriend doing that you know what i'm
saying me it's the whole double speak
that these guys do it's like oh my girl
can be thirst trapping uh but if i want
to do it it's perfectly fine it's like
okay yeah if you're making millions of
dollars and you want them high value
dudes that's fine but most [ __ ]
watching your [ __ ] are poor so them
rules don't apply to them so let's talk
about real people let's not just talk
about what rich [ __ ] do so do you
think maybe it's like that you're being
disingenuous but that you appeal to
normal people rather than trying to
elevate people
uh sneaker at the end of the day most
people are never gonna be filthy rich
you're the exception you're the one
percent that's not possible
i'm not rich but like i tell my child
every day like
you are you are you are whether you
realize it
sneaker you make well over six figures
yeah you are you are less than one
percent
i'm still like my my student loans are
being paid off this week so technically
i'm in debt
it doesn't matter whether you're getting
your
your
your projected income for this year and
for the next subsequent years you are
less than one percenter it's projected
because i'm putting in the work
but right now i i don't disagree on
paper i have negative money
i i'm not disagreeing with you that you
didn't work hard i'm not saying that
what i'm trying to say is the rules that
dating that exists for you as somebody
who's making a lot more money who has a
lot more flexibility are not gonna be
the same rules of dating that exists for
the everyday person do you understand
that
okay
that's fair but shouldn't we encourage
men to strive to be high value men
instead of just accepting their
place on the totem pole
no i don't think you should be pushing
people to strive to be that should be
complacent because here's the thing it's
one thing to say hey guys if you want to
get to this level cool congratulations
most people are never going to get to
live that life
but they understand that a lot of guys
give okay but here's my problem with a
lot of guys give up and instead of
admitting where they're at or trying to
improve they make up excuses for why
like they'll say the crypto guys that
i'm doing videos with they got lucky
with their investments it's like no you
don't get lucky like being smart puts
you in lucky positions everybody can get
it now the internet allows everyone to
be rich you're making that face but
money now is all numbers on your phone
okay sneaker you understand that the
whole principle of rich is the whole
idea of abundance that if you have an
abundance somebody has to have less
yeah but everybody watching this stream
has an internet connection so we all
have the capability to get there
we all have the capability to get that
there but it's only the resources are
finite
it's not possible for everybody to be
filthy rich it's not possible it is
it is if they if they have a phone that
it is there's no excuse anymore with the
phone connection all the information's
online all the stuff that i've learned
about how to make videos about how to
make money have been from youtube
tutorials everything we all have the
capability to get rich and like i think
you saying that is like encouraging
complacency when because it's getting so
much harder for men we should not
encourage that behavior like no no no
that's not what i'm doing i'm not trying
to encourage people to be complacent
what i'm trying to tell you is that your
paradigm is all [ __ ] up the idea that
everyone can be rich is one not backable
by any [ __ ] economist in the world
nobody would ever say everybody could be
rich however what i am trying to say is
you don't need to be rich to lead a good
life to live a life of happiness i don't
know about you and where you've lived
specifically but i've had the luxury of
living all over even in the states when
i go to the south a lot of people out
there aren't talking about being filthy
rich if they can have their home have
they farm have they land have their guns
have their wife they're happy not
everybody needs to be quote unquote rich
to live a good life and when you sell
this paradigm to people you're
inherently making so that vast majority
of your audience who buy into this will
always be unhappy because they'll never
be able to reach something that is not
it's not feasible for everybody so what
i'm trying for everybody if we all have
a phone and interconnection and we could
all download coinbase gemini we could
all make content we could all just ecom
there's a million [ __ ] ways to make
money online
i think you'd have to probably sit down
with an economist for him to break down
all the numbers for you why but what i'm
because you're asking me how to explain
the breakdown of resources in the world
and how not everybody can have an
abundance if everyone has an abundance
the word abundance doesn't even exist
richness nearly determinates that you
have more than others
you understand that to get rich in the
first place you need to accept the
realities of the world and that things
are unfair and you need to apply
yourself okay okay okay
what you're saying a lot of people hear
what you're saying and just accept yeah
i'm never gonna be rich and then they
won't if you think that way you will not
get rich but if you think it's possible
i have to get rich get rich or die
trying more likely than not you will
sneak out
this is like one of those things where i
feel like people think everyone's the
main character okay
no not everyone is the main character
some people are side characters some
people are really good uh role players
within the storyline not everyone gets
to be a main character not everyone gets
to live by the same role not everyone
gets to be a king okay there are kings
there are jesters there are other people
but not everyone gets to live at the top
that's just not the way the world is
built but the world for average men now
is getting harder and like the average
man is invisible now
yeah okay i don't disagree with that so
we can talk about that but the solution
to that is not making everyone a high
value man even kevin samuels will tell
you that's not even possible to god rest
his soul that's not possible for
everyone to be filthy rich which is why
kevin always talked about encouraging
these women to understand the importance
of a blue-collar person and to be
respectful of them because the guy doing
your plumbing is extremely important
society and even though he might not be
the most rich person he still brings
the ability to give you stability his
goal with what he was saying wasn't that
everybody got to be rich and all these
thoughts got to get with kings no what
he was trying to say is that your
standards are unreasonable and that you
don't deserve that so relax
you understand you can't just sit there
telling me to relax and calm down
what i am telling them is that everyone
trying to buy into this whole like i'm
gonna get rich one day is making them
miserable because it's not possible so
if you are possible like i i don't
understand you're telling me to ask an
economist but you're also saying just
give up it's not possible but it is if
you okay okay okay okay okay so point me
one place on the society where
everyone's rich
where's the society
because look the rules of the game now
all of capitalism is a game and since
birth they suppress you and tell you to
go into these worlds go into debt in
school get this job here do this take
your meds and so instead of like
realizing that they can get rich if they
apply themselves they give up
it is possible but the game is rigged
against them so the rich get richer and
the poor get poorer
okay
okay
so that's not true are you are you
saying are you saying throughout all of
society and all of world history
the reason why there wasn't an entire
society of rich people is because they
didn't work hard enough
is because not because they didn't work
hard enough but they've been brainwashed
to think that they need to relax and
calm down that they need to accept their
place in society instead of striving for
more and the reason they think that is
because the people at the top do not
want those people to challenge their
position but i'm saying [ __ ] those
people [ __ ] them all at the top touch
the kids on islands
suck my dick i'm gonna get there i don't
not what the part with the kids but i
wanted my own island with some bad
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you getting everything
taking private jets all over the world
telling me what i can and can't do what
i should inject and what i shouldn't
inject telling us to quarantine because
of some gay std from monkeys
they're going to keep us inside again
you know that and now i see it i thought
everybody was going to think that the
monkey [ __ ] was a joke and now people
are like why are we locking down again
that mentality is why so many people
aren't rich and why people think it's
not possible
so you think that if people aren't rich
they're going to be miserable
it's getting harder to be happy if
you're an average person because i know
that but that's not what i ask you i ask
you if people aren't rich can they be
happy they can they can but they also
need to
they need to be complacent to some
extent and i'm the type of guy where i
need to have complete freedom to be
happy if i feel any restrictions on me
and i think a lot of men naturally feel
like that if someone's telling you what
to do there's a part of you that's being
suppressed because men naturally you
just want to conquer like i i get pissed
off when people have more than me or
like i see hotels and resorts like why
can't i own that why can't i get that
okay okay but let's just take a couple
steps back so you agree with me that
it's not because people are poor that
they can't be happy correct yeah
okay
good so we're on the same page so my
prescription to people isn't that you
have to aspire to be rich or perspire to
be this what i'm trying to sell folks is
you can be happy regardless of your
financial situation well i mean above a
certain level obviously if you're like
struggling to make your rent every month
then obviously that's a different
situation but past like 40 50k in most
cities not every city you're gonna be
okay so now that
listen maybe not new york okay but if
you take 50k and you go to a lot of
major cities yes you're going to be good
okay so let me just yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes
yes so
past a certain point what i want to
discuss is what are the things that lead
people to be happy outside of money i
think we have such a fixation on
material goods good relationship you
need freedom you need to be able to do
what you want to speak when you see a
good relationship what does that mean a
good relationship with the people around
you your friends your family and your
woman
okay all right so community right yeah
okay now let me ask you of the two
things let me know which was more
important do you think it's more
important for somebody to have 50k
and have a good community or for someone
to have a million dollars but have no
community which one do you think is
better
50k with the community it probably yes
but okay okay okay
can i respond to that
they are trying to separate community
now they're trying to divide us more
than ever you know what they did during
the kovi they said to not like
discommunicate with your family who
didn't take this don't talk to them if
someone's not wearing glue
don't talk to them they try to divide us
more more if you voted for this orange
guy and not the older guy then don't
talk to him they try to divide us more
if you don't put a black square on your
instagram then you're racist they try to
divide us more more so they community is
falling apart like so many people are so
polarized because of what they believe
in and their standings and it's all
encouraged from the top they say you
need to believe in this
like you need to put ukraine in your bio
put this go fam and everyone's just like
is so political that there's a lack of
community and that's why i need to go
okay
the idea is that people the people's
world views are so
different that there's a genuine lack of
community and especially on social media
is making it worse
so
just taking a couple steps back so we
started off at
young men are really miserable and
they're unhappy right and then we talked
about income and you agreed with me that
even with 50k it's probably better to
have 50 000 a year and have a really
good sense of community family uh
significant other friends than it is for
you to be extremely wealthy and have
nobody around you so you put community
above money yes right but it's almost
impossible to have a good community now
as a young man with 50k it's almost
impossible
but that's that's not true that's nice
okay why is it impossible because of how
divided everybody is because of how
they except they literally say stand six
feet apart there you go separating
community cover your face i can't talk
to you don't look at me put a shield
over you they're dividing people they
don't want you to have community anymore
sit in this seat and take away the chair
in the middle so you can't look at
someone else
okay okay i don't disagree that during
the pendant it's probably hard to have
and there's another one coming there's
another the monkey things just started
the world okay who just declared it
and if it turns out to be an extended
thing that we're going to deal with for
many more years to come but i think
you'll have well hey we will see and if
you do then i will i will see to you
that although i i i'm conceding to you
i'm saying you're right okay brief i'm
saying you're correct if we have to
continuously live in lockdown in
perpetuity where we never get to spend
time with other people and be around
other folks i would agree with you that
it is extremely dangerous for people and
it makes it untenable to have
communities okay do you have anything
conceding to you okay do you know how
many people i talk to who are like man i
just moved out i got a job of making
money but like how do i make friends
where do i talk to people like i can't
go to school because my school's shut
down
okay well listen i can't speak about
everything i know you say it's all
connected so for me it's just it's too
large in scope
of government do you trust the
government
i trust her for some things and i don't
trust it for others i think the
government [ __ ] up in some places and
it does well in others
that's how i kind of view it and so if
you want to go think case by case fine
but you know government operates in
different branches it's hard to say the
government it's like saying do you think
the shoe industry is good it's like what
company some companies are worse than
others some of them are ethical some of
them are not you can't just question i
feel like i feel like i feel like when i
hear you speak you speak so broadly i
don't know what is your talk about what
do you think about women what does that
mean like you have to be more specific
and so that's what i'm saying let's just
focus on one thing okay and then we'll
go from there to something i've been
ranting like yeah yeah i know i know
you've been passionate you've been
passionate yeah